bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans europe
hebdo vous êtes bien sur les chaînes
parlementaires et nous sommes à
strasbourg au coeur du parlement
européen oui katia et dans la partie
magazine de cette émission nous irons au
portugal sur le barrage d'alqueva un
barrage qui a été financé en très grande
partie par des fonds européens
actualités économiques cette semaine
reprises aux récessions à quoi la zone
euro doit elle s'attendre
c'est la question de la semaine en ces
temps d'austérité générale en europe
sa parole vaut de l'or depuis les
hauteurs de davos en suisse où se
réunissent et les grands argentiers de
la planète
mario draghi a parlé le président de la
banque centrale européenne fait souffler
un vent d'optimisme sur la zone euro
depuis seuls chinois à la bce
nous estimons que la situation
économique est en train de se stabiliser
à des niveaux très faibles et nous nous
attendons à une reprise au cours du
second semestre de cette année les
premiers signes sont l'art regain de
confiance des ménages et des
investisseurs exportations à la hausse
taux d'intérêt légèrement à la baisse et
surtout avis de grand calme sur les
marchés
mais pas si vite l'embellie n'est pas
contagieuse l'allemagne mise à part la
plupart des économies européennes sont
toujours dans une situation difficile
le chômage atteint un nouveau record
11,8 pour cent dans la zone euro et
continue de faire des ravages en europe
du sud grèce italie espagne ou un actif
sur quatre est sans travail au plus fort
de la crise mario draghi avait joué un
rôle central en rachetant massivement
les dettes des pays malades
aujourd'hui la menace d'un effondrement
général de la zone euro est loin mais la
croissance pas encore là
voilà dessine des indices des
indicateurs contradictoires comment les
interpréter on en parle justement avec
notre invité qui va nous apporter son
éclairage
bonjour robert rochefort bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe des démocrates
et libéraux pour l'europe vice président
du modem et vous êtes aussi économiste
ancien président du credoc le centre de
recherche pour l'étude et l'observation
des conditions de vie un poste que vous
avez quitté pour vous consacrer à plein
temps à votre mandat européen alors
mario draghi auguste président de la
banque centrale européenne paris lui
sera un retour prochain de la croissance
en tout cas il pense qu'il y aura une
reprise
est ce que c'est il ya effectivement des
raisons d'espérer cette reprise ou pour
vous c'est une méthode coué trop
rationnellement il y a deux petits
facteurs fade de petits deux facteurs
qui incitent effectivement est-ce qu'il
puisse y avoir une reprise
premièrement c'est le fait que
l'économie américaine effectivement
redémarre et c'est le fait aussi que les
autres économies internationales
je pense à l'afrique a dit fort autant
dans un autre endroit du monde sont
aussi en train de repartir mais je
trouve extrêmement dangereux que
l'europe soit à attendre sa propre
croissance de la croissance des autres
parce que pour ce qui est de l'europe
elle-même c'est-à-dire sa capacité
productive de sa capacité à générer de
la croissance par ces forces internes
là malheureusement nous sommes à l'arrêt
il faut le dire cette année
l'économie européenne est à l'arrêt donc
si reprise il ya je ne suis même pas sûr
qu'elle intervienne au deuxième semestre
de cette année comme le dit mario draghi
elle finira évidemment par revenir un
peu probablement en début 2014
mais je ne suis pas aussi optimiste que
mario draghi
même si pourtant je reconnais que grâce
à lui nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation bien meilleure que il ya un an
à la même époque
mais ça c'est à cause de l'euro c'est
pas la question de la croissance
économique
de quoi dépend cette croissance qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait pour que pour que la
alors les économies espérées
fous rires sont deux choses la première
c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait fini ou à peu
près fini l'aspect le plus drastique de
la la diète et la sévérité interne au
niveau de la zone euro alors il ya
encore cette année nous sommes
probablement dans l'année de la plus
difficile parce que les plans de rigueur
dans les différents pays de la zone euro
son maximum cette année
et puis deuxièmement il faut qu'on
relance l'activité économique
on ne peut la relancer que de deux
façons par l'innovation premièrement et
là l'europe a un rôle à jouer
il se trouve qu'on est en plein en ce
moment vous le savez dans le débat sur
le budget européen et il faut qu'il y
ait dans le budget européen pour les
années qui viennent des marges de
manoeuvre qui permette de relancer des
initiatives de croissance
ça c'est la première chose et
deuxièmement il faut que l'europe joue
beaucoup plus ensemble
il faut par exemple que la france
l'allemagne l'angleterre l'italie ne met
pas d'abord leurs priorités économiques
dans des éléments de politique nationale
mais ceux capables de fédérer leurs
énergies
je vous donne un exemple par exemple les
trains à grande vitesse
il faut enfin que les allemands avec
siemens les français avec alstom soit
capable de fédérer leurs forces pour
refaire pour les années qui viennent
ce qu'on a fait avec airbus et quelques
dizaines d'années tant que nous n'aurons
pas une logique à la fois commune dans
l'effort et puis de dégager des marges
de manoeuvre en faisant des économies
sur les budgets de fonctionnement pour
avoir des dépenses d'investissement la
croissance ne repartira pas vraiment
alors on parlait de l'euro françois
hollande devant les députés européens a
relancé le débat sur l'euro l' la france
aimerait bien qu'il soit moins fort on a
l'impression qu'elle est
la seule à le penser dans tous les pays
qui sont des pays qui ne sont pas aussi
exportateurs j'allais dire que
l'allemagne ont intérêt à ce que l'euro
soit moins fort il est exact que
l'allemagne en tirer bénéfice parce
qu'elle arrive à vendre ses exportations
quel que soit le prix parce qu'elle est
très très bonne dans les exportations
mais il faut effectivement que l'europe
soit moins fort alors je précise
néanmoins que vous savez les mones et
des logiques comparative 6e l'euro est
trop fort c'est pas uniquement parce
qu'il est trop fort en soi c'est aussi
parce que les autres monnaies sont trop
faibles
mais nous devons aller et ça c'est un
vrai vrai chantier dans un système
monétaire mondial dans lequel on met fin
à cette disproportion de parité parce
que en tout cas le taux de l'euro
aujourd'hui n'a pas de signification
économique réelle par rapport à la force
de l'économie européenne
il est plus fort que le lait l'économie
lyon en attendant de convaincre les
chinois les américains de se concerter
sur des taux de change est ce que
peuvent faire à leur échelle les
européens
est ce que le conseil européen peut
décider d'un taux de change qui serait
donc de surveiller les banques centrales
européennes sont les banques centrales
du monde sont indépendantes même si
elles ont pris en compte des contraintes
de croissance qu'elle n'avait pas avant
c'est une très très bonne chose mais
bien sûr que les politiques et les
gouvernements ne peuvent pas dire on va
dicter de cette façon là le cours de
l'euro par ailleurs la banque centrale
européenne a inondé le marché de
liquidités pour justement permettre que
les banques ne fassent pas faillite et
même que les états les plus faibles et
la centrale 7 seront les centrales mais
elle a inondé de liquidités donc elle ne
peut plus tellement en inondant de
liquidités faire baisser l'euro donc il
est incontestable que les cours des
différentes monnaies devront se faire
par des concertations internationales
mais nous avons des possibilités de le
faire parce que de l'autre côté
regardez avec les états unis on est en
train de négocier commencé à négocier un
accord de libre échange entre les états
unis et l'europe
là la question de la parité des monnaies
ré-entre également
content et on en reparlera sûrement
d'ici là merci j'en suis sûr merci
robert rochoise d'avoir été avec nous on
vous laisse repartir dans la musique
parce que vous êtes très pressé et non
poursuit cette émission place tout de
suite au zapping été les héros pn avec
bien sûr le discours de françois
hollande à strasbourg sa position sur le
budget étaient attendus devant les
députés françois hollande dégaine une
formule choc faire les économies
oui affaiblir l'économie
non françois jetté compris
le changement c'est maintenant alors
allons-y tout droit chiche et banco et
ne nous raconte pas d'histoires entre
nous même s'il ya beaucoup de
spectateurs le montant des chèques et
des rabais doit cesser d'augmenter et
pour l'avenir de véritables ressources
propres seront indispensables
un compromis est possible mais il doit
être raisonnable est une forme
automatique on est maintenant ce n est
qu un soldat
enfin l'europe est un continent où la
croissance est trop faible
- chômage de masse révèle la profondeur
de la crise qui n'est pas seulement
comme on l'a dit une condition passagère
mais une mutation profonde
voilà pour ces quelques extraits du
discours de françois hollande dans
l'hémicycle de strasbourg pour en parler
nous sommes avec un correspondant rail
cogan bonjour le correspondant au
parlement européen de la radiotélévision
irlandaise rte
e comme erin en gaélique merci alors
revenons à ce discours qui était quand
même une première pour un chef d'état
dont le pays ne préside pas l'union
européenne comment est-ce que ce
discours at-il été interprétés et reçu
dans votre pays en irlande
évidemment c'est un important lien entre
les gouvernements et le parlement ici à
strasbourg
mais il faut aussi parler du continue
donc qu'est ce qu'on a à elle parlé de
la solidarité
chouette elle parlait du elle a expliqué
que l'austérité sans arêtes
est hors ducation ça c'est super beau ci
et là aussi défendu la situation du
strasbourg comme la capitale européenne
qui va en paix qui va provoquer
certainement la plupart des membres du
parlement sauf ce qui vient d'alsace
d'allemagne de l'ouest
mais d'un point de vue du can du contenu
des choses exactes des choses précis a
beaucoup dans ceux de ce qu pas beaucoup
dans ce discours à mon avis notamment
suggéré une grande réforme des
institutions qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est une bonne chose ok franchement je
vais partager un secret maintenant si
vous voulez comprendre la vie
hollandaise sur n'importe quel sujet en
europe
maintenant il faut prendre en compte
deux mots clés dette bancaire
donc on a entendu réforme on a entendu
solidarité mais sans vrai vraiment des
chiffres et des suggestions sur ce point
là des soucis peut-être pour filer
exactement exactement
d'un point de vue historique il y avait
certainement des choses très positif
dans ce discours mais comme beaucoup d
autres pays en difficulté
on a de plus en plus l'impression que
les décisions sont pris aux berlin base
à bruxelles dans peut-être pour nous
c'est mieux si françois hollande était
le chancelier allemand est pas le
président de la république française je
sais pas alors ce n'est pas le cas en
tout cas qu'est ce que vous attendez de
positif dans ce discours fleuve
il y avait des choses positives mais
aussi des contradictions quand même un
hôtel par exemple et là parler elle n'a
pas nommés qui les britanniques mais il
commençait à parler de danger des pays
qui souffre leur intérêt national
puis à la fin elle parlait du strasbourg
et strasbourg comme la capitale de
l'union européen
évidemment ça c'est très important pour
la france très important pour certains
allemands et bien sûr pour l'alsace mais
pour la plupart des membres du parlement
européen
c'est fou d'avoir une soeur qui
bruxelles pour strasbourg chaque mois
qui coûtent des millions d'euros donc
elle parlait d intérêt national et les
dangers des gens qui suivre les entrées
nationales
or en dépit des entrées européen et puis
il fait exactement la même chose donc
c'est un peu drôle qui sont peut-être
sur le mali pour terminer il a salué les
députés européens pour leur soutien dans
cette intervention au mali en même temps
la français est seul sur place oui moi
moi j'étais un peu étonné pour ça parce
que il y avait beaucoup de soutien pour
l'intervention au mali et au cou des
membres du parlement pas de pas
seulement les membres français ou des à
des allemands qui a exprimé leur
gratitude pour ce que la france fait au
mali parce que évidemment si l'art en
cenne toujours seul et sur le terrain de
la france et seuls est évidemment un
problème à marly ça peut devenir en
afghanistan trois heures et rien de
l'europe donc évidemment c'est important
bien merci
rake organes pour jouer un prix au
regard sur l'actualité de cette semaine
place tout de suite à la deuxième partie
de cette émission n'aura hamadi sera
avec son invité alors les questions
budgétaires reviennent sur le devant de
la scène européenne nous avons voulu
savoir comment était utilisé les fonds
européens donné par l'union européenne
exemple avec ce reportage tourné dans le
sud du portugal où un barrage a été
construit il ya dix ans at il tenu
toutes ses promesses
regardez ce reportage signé et les abers
tholomé georges abbou cours et henrique
pinto coelho
alem des jo sud du portugal
à l'origine de ce paysage de carte
postale le barrage d'alqueva une
construction de 500 mètres de long et
100 mètres de haut
mais ça
parce que chaque jour manuelle vient
pêcher ici sur ce barrage souvent ici
parce qu'avec le barrage la zone de
baisse a augmenté il y à d'autres bases
dans le coin mais nous venons plus ici
alc et va parce qu'il est plus grand
avant il n'y avait ici qu'une petite
rivière
aujourd'hui c'est le plus grand lac
d'europe 85 km de long une réserve d'eau
de 4 milliards de mètres cubes
c'est l'entreprise et dia qui est chargé
de son exploitation
un chantier gigantesque qui a duré 26
ans et qui répondait à plusieurs
demandes
la première pour que les habitants aient
de l'eau la seconde pour qu'il y ait de
l'eau pour l'industrie la troisième
c'est pour que nous puissions produire
de l'électricité
et puis la dernière pour que l'eau
puisse être utilisé par les
exploitations agricoles gris quoi pour
faire venir l'eau du lac un système de
canaux a dû être construit prévu pour
ce chantier ne sera terminée qu'en 2015
trois ans de retard alors que les
agriculteurs attendaient beaucoup de cet
aménagement dans une région aussi sèche
pour les cultures
l'eau est une nécessité los del qu'eva
vient directement ici 230 hectares de
vignes grâce à l'eau du lac
cette eau il nous aide à mieux arroser
et à avoir une meilleure production de
raisins 2,5 milliards d'euros ont été
investis dans la région
65 % viennent du fond européen de
développement régional de l'union
européenne 35% du gouvernement portugais
objectif créer une réserve stratégique
d'eau pour lutter contre la sécheresse
et développé toute une région
chaque euro investi par l'europe et le
portugal
le gain est d'un euro cinquante six pour
le portugal
et ce gars aurait pu être plus important
si un aspect n'avait pas été laissée au
second plan le tourisme
ce terrain était le terrain pour le
projet en chaos
c'était un projet de grande envergure et
devait y avoir des activités
touristiques un golf des logements mais
un projet finalement abandonné faute de
financements
et ce n'est pas une exception à cause du
manque de suivi par les autorités et de
la crise plusieurs autres grands
aménagements ont été annulés ou reportés
pire aucune structure en particulier ne
gère l'aspect touristique du lac dal
qu'eva pour ces professionnels
la peine est double ce serait bien que
les organismes touristiques a presque
plus de place à cette destination
pour cela il faut qu'il y ait plus
d'aménagements mais la conjoncture
n'êtes pas nous sommes au point mort en
stand by mais à qui profite le barrage
d'alqueva ce journaliste spécialiste du
sujet dénonce les installations ont
certes attiré des investisseurs mais des
étrangers
bob la main d'oeuvre qui travaillent
dans cette oliveraie est roumaine
ukrainienne brésilienne bref il ya très
peu de portugais ici il est très rare
d'en voir où travaillent pour le travail
produit vient de l'étranger
eva hors de la région et ceux qui sont
les siens des migrants la problématique
de l'exode francisco oliveira la connaît
bien
depuis 1994 il est maire de luz un
village noyés par le lac et reconstruit
à l'identique
quelques kilomètres plus haut sur la
rive
400 habitants en 2002 ils sont moins de
300 aujourd'hui et pour le maire c'est
la faute aux barrages
ils nous ont fait une promesse ils nous
ont dit que dans la nouvelle luz il
allait construire 15 résidences sociales
ils ne l'ont pas fait les jeunes couples
sont partis entre 95 et 2008 de ce
hameau
parce qu'ici il ne pouvait pas
construire de maisons acheté le terrain
depuis la vie semble s'être arrêté à luz
à l'époque le barrage d'alqueva suscité
beaucoup d'espoir dix ans après la fin
des travaux il reste comme un goût
d'inachevé
non
et voici donc pour ce reportage réalisé
au portugal par elisa bertolo mais en
attendant nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
james ls bonjour vous êtes député
européen britannique vous faites partie
du groupe des réformateurs et
conservateurs c'est bien ça et surtout
vous faites partie de la commission des
budgets vous en avez même été rapporteur
il ya quelques années alors on a vu un
reportage en fait sur ce barrage au
portugal qui a coûté la bagatelle de 2
milliards et demi d'euros qui a mis 27
ans à sortir de terre
est-ce qu'il ya pas un problème global
de contrôle des fonds européens comment
est ce qu un projet comme celui-là peut
prendre 27 en disant que dans les
infrastructures c'est très bien que ça
peut prendre beaucoup de temps serait ce
que pour cette question de barrage pour
les autoroutes pour les aéroports
d'autres choses comme ça mais
normalement il un poursuivi qui est
suivi ne serait ce que par la commission
elle même par les gouvernements qui sont
concernés et puis pour nous en tant que
parlementaire européen où nous avons le
pouvoir de refuser une décharge sur un
budget annuel et nous voyons ça dans
notre mission du contrôle budgétaire
mais est-ce que vous utilisez assez
finalement ce pouvoir que vous avez vous
le parlement européen sur ces questions
disons que ce que cette commission fait
sur le contrôle budgétaire
chaque année elle doit donner un des
charges sur les dépenses de l'année a
pas avant c'est à dire que nous avons un
peut-être un période de deux ans une
fois que le budget est établi
puis les argents sont dépensés et puis
après on à l'analyse des
des fonds quand j'étais rapporteur dont
il y à un quinzaine d'années en fait ça
a mené un des sages qui n'a jamais été
donnée parce que celui qui a dit qu'il
ne fallait pas le faire parce que en
fait les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies pour n'en donner ça ne se passe
pas toujours évidemment mais c'était une
question de manière dont laquelle les
fonds étaient dépensés donc le parlement
et a le pouvoir de le faire et ce que
nous avons besoin tant que député ces
les informations qui viennent des
sources publiques normalement pour qu'on
puisse juger si on donne se décharge
mais le problème c'est que ces sources
justement qui viennent certainement des
pays pourquoi ne pas mettre en place au
niveau du parlement européen une vraie
commission qui puisse en elle-même
allez vérifier qu'il n'ya pas de gabegie
qu'il n'y a pas de 2,2 ouvrons ces fonds
et pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya tant de
retard mais c'est exact en fait c'est
cette commission du contrôle budgétaire
moi je suis sur le commission des
budgets depuis presque trente ans
maintenant mais dans le contrôle
budgétaire houzet 6 et pour quelques
années
là on a tous les renseignements
nécessaires pour les programmes
extérieur ou intérieur de l'union
et si une plainte est déposée c'est
cette commission qui reprend en charge
pour ramener les gens ensemble et pour
voir la vérité ce qu'il existe alors
justement il y à une personne que nous
avons vu dans ce reportage qui est une
question directe à vous poser on les
écoute
qu'est que ouf pourquoi les responsables
européens ne visite pas n'accompagne pas
ne supervise pas plus l'exploitation des
projets comme celui d'al quéven
alors james et l'ess pourquoi est ce que
l'europe ne supervise pas plus est ce
qu'au fond ils ne seraient pas bonnes
qu'à signer des chèques et elle ne pas
regarder ce qui se passe sur le terrain
moi je crois que ce qui se passe
normalement c'est que quand il ya des
scandales qui arrivait que la presse
nous amène parce que complètement c'est
la poisse qui découvre quand l'argent
mais très bien dépensé comme ça ils à
cette relation de sources d'information
et maintenant avec l'internet on a
beaucoup moins d' excuse de ne pas
savoir ce qui se passe sur le terrain
alors à ce moment là un dossier été
créée dérange les gens sont responsables
doivent plus alors je dirais dans ce
cas-ci à cette personne qui a demandé la
question ramenez moi les renseignements
et en mettre dans nos commissions pour
voir exactement ce qui se dit ce qu'ils
demandent c'est un contrôle global
surtout le projet comme par exemple un
suivi complet d'une agence sur place
parce que on voit qu'effectivement la
question du tourisme n'a pas du tout
était et est développé que le projet a
mis 27 ans à arriver et que en plus le
lac artificiel qui doit être fournie en
même temps n'est pas complètement
terminée donc en fait on se rend bien
compte qu'il ya un problème de suivi je
dirais même plus de gestion de projet
sur cette question oui alors la première
question supposerait j'imagine que cette
mélange défend des fonds nationaux ce
n'est pas seulement le budget européen
qui donc à ce moment là on devrait avoir
des structures déjà en place à la
commission européenne avec le
gouvernement portugais de voir
exactement ce qui s'est passé dans ce
projet ce qui ne va pas parce que
clairement les choses ne vont pas et que
des objectifs ne sont pas réunies et à
ce moment-là ce dossier doive être
présenté moi je serai le député si vous
voulez qui pourrait le faire parce que à
chaque instant il faut toujours donner
la confiance aux gens aux peuples
européens quels efforts sont bien gérées
et que nous avons ce qu'on appellerait
en anglais vallée faymann et c'est à
dire qu'on a à rentabilité quand il a
tellement peu d'argent qui existe pour
les projets publics il faut que y
fonctionne alors il ya un autre problème
sur les fonds européens on est censé
développer aussi l'emploi autour de ces
infrastructures
or on voit par exemple que sur cette
infrastructure particulière au portugal
mais c'est aussi le cas
hier et bien finalement les emplois
créés n'ont pas bénéficié aux locaux
n'ont pas bénéficié aux portugais est-ce
que ça c'est pas un écueil de l'union
européenne de ne pas être capable de
protéger ses concitoyens et de leur
offrir en fait des possibilités d'emploi
je crois que il y a quand même d'autres
cas que celui ci au portugal que on
entend par exemple les projets en
afghanistan qui sont faites par la
communauté internationale que beaucoup
trop d'argent va envers les consultants
et pas sur les personnes qui sont sur le
terrain et 7 malheur de parfois de cette
aide internationale que on donne ça aux
gens qui se servent de cet apport aux
mêmes et pas pour les en fait les bus
exacte du projet ce que je dirai dans ce
cas encore il faut voir quels étaient
les objectifs dès le début si c'est
écrit que cet argent p1 est là ne pas
seulement pour faire l'infrastructure
mais pour créer les emplois locaux
il faut voir pourquoi ça n'a pas été
fait alors dernière question très
rapidement la grèce l'espagne le
portugal sont des pays qui sont un petit
peu en chute libre dans la zone euro qui
ont du mal à se redresser face à la
récession
est ce que le feder peut être un levier
et est ce que finalement assez dans ces
moments où on parle de budget tronquée
il faudrait pas encore plus finalement
lui donner des fonds bon je les ai ma
réponse c'est là à un grand nez que
c'est ce qui va s'ouvrir au conseil
européen cette semaine c'est sur le
budget pour les prochains sept ans à mon
avis on verra que on est très restreint
pour l'argent qui est disponible et on
voit que tout l'argent qui pourrait
donner pour les projets imaginative sur
l'innovation recherche seront coupés
pour donner ça aux autres
est ce que je dirais c'est que si on n'a
pas de décision ce n'est pas un
catastrophe parce que ce qu'il faut
faire dans les fonds par exemple pour le
feder pour cp méditerranée qui sont
vraiment en difficulté par rapport aux
finances il faut voir que l'argent est
vraiment bien dépensé dans l'intérêt des
citoyens et ne pas de faire des couloirs
des gens qui ne peut-être ne mérite pas
autant
merci beaucoup john's à l'aise d'avoir
été notre invité pour nous cette
émission est terminé mais on se retrouve
quinze jours à bruxelles avec 4,5
gilbert et françois beaudonnet pour
d'autres actualités européenne bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires